ça c'est ce que j'ai moi sur marketplace
à langer une toile que j'ai depuis une
vingtaine d'années en fait que je n'ai
plus besoin alors je les mets en vente
ma requête plus est la plateforme de
prédilection de jouer à mario
elle y achète et vend tout ou presque
j'ai réalisé à quel point il y avait des
vêtements des meubles toutes sortes de
biens qui étaient jetés
je me suis donné comme défi en allemand
beaucoup la nature l'environnement et ou
de faire ma part et d'acheter au moins
75% de 2 ce que j'avais besoin d'essayer
de trouver seconde main en cinq ans
l'économie de l'usagé ou de seconde main
s'est imposé au canada en 2010 8 82 %
des canadiens y ont pris part
2 milliards 400 millions d'objets soit
250 millions de plus qu'il ya cinq ans
on peut ainsi avoir une seconde vie en
changeant de mains
la valeur des transactions s'est élevé à
plus de 27 milliards de dollars
les provinces de l'ouest sont les
championnes de cette économie
l'alberta la colombie-britannique année
après année en fait ressortent comme
étant au-dessus du lot tant on en termes
d du nombre de bien changer que du
pourcentage la partie par la population
qui participent mais les plateformes
kijiji market place et autres sont en
train de faire le plein d'adeptes au
québec notamment
aujourd'hui une personne sur cinq y
rendant le marché l'économie de seconde
main passe par la plateforme qui ré plus
connus kijiji mais elle rend d'abord par
ces canaux l'an les plates formes ne
sont plus les seuls à occuper le créneau
de visage et flairant la bonne affaire
et les préoccupations environnementales
des consommateurs des chaînes comme ikea
et le marchand européen de chaussures
eram récupèrent leurs produits déjà
utilisé les répare et les revendent
arabe est ici maxime bertrand radio
canada montréal
[Musique]